well i taught several places one i was
teaching close to home when i taught at
inglewood high then i taught at
westchester and that of course you head
in west you're not passing through too
many hoods like that outside of
inglewood
and then um but it was when i taught on
vermont and 60th coming from century and
la brea that it's like okay i'm out of
this neighborhood in inglewood through
these other three neighborhoods in
inglewood through you know what i'm
saying
you know the i tried to you know it's
like all these different hoods well but
you have to stop and get gas come on now
you weaken gas on our side right right
before you get in there you know and um
and
and then of course there's an exception
to every world i've stopped to get gas
in another hood you know and if you
you kind of hope that somebody ain't
having a bad enough day to where they
not listen to reason or that or to where
they don't ask no questions at all you
know because that happens it had been
times where it was like they just pulled
up and start busting that's tragic you
know but then there's been times where
i'd have been pressed and i could tell
he looking at me like waiting for me to
say the wrong thing and i could tell he
got a gun on him like hand all tucked in
everything and i'm like
you know what i'm saying and it's just a
matter of
you know have you mastered yourself
enough to be to look them in the eyes
and be like i'm solid bro i hope all is
well with you you know and just let them
make that decision to be like do i want
to do do i want to do a good human being
harm and i think even behind all the
gang stuff
there's there's this
people have to be triggered or pushed
over that little edge and sometimes fear
of pushing being scary will push people
over the edge
you know it'll trigger that uh
that instinct that predatory instinct if
you look like oh too
all is well bro god bless you you know
but it's direct it's like i'm not scared
of you but i'm looking into you like
i know what i know what you got you know
what i'm saying and if you're gonna do
it you're gonna have to live with the
fact that you did it in the wrong
situation you know because fear tells on
a lot of people some people are afraid
because they know they might be on the
bad side of some well-deserved karma
they might have done something similar
out there ah you know that's not my
story so if you gonna pull up
if you're gonna pull up and bust on d
smoke you're gonna bust on somebody that
is proud of what he did
done right by his family and his
business partners and i'ma look you in
your eyes like damn is this that
because we all got our day you feel me
like and i don't it's not that i want to
go but it's like i've
seen i've been in those situations where
it could have been that you know so and
and a lot of so much is outside your
control so like you're referring to uh
find my way
you know in so many ways it's like
we're all navigating as a teacher i'm
still navigating i'm navigating
like
like the law one you know what i'm
saying california is it's hard to have a
gun you know what i'm saying i'm
navigating the law i'm navigating uh
you know going in there wanting to be
effective with the kids but i'm in the
middle of the hood and it's a lot
working against me just a mindset you
know